also making news Kate Hudson there she
is with her man Danny Fujikawa taking a
baby for a stroll in New York and that's
exactly where Kevin Frazier is and I
gotta say though Kate is one busy mom
Kevin she Hey she is everywhere and that
means we had a lot of ground to cover
when we sat down to chat there's a
couple things that people always want to
talk about especially with me they
always want to ask about my family you
want to ask about my regime and they
want to ask about my love life okay so
that's all be talking about today you
have a teenager and now you have a baby
it's like the family like Huddle's
around and it's like everyone gets their
strategy and then we're like you know hi
like let's do this there's seven seven
years apart so Ryder's 7 from Bing and
Bing seven virani
which means I basically been having
children my entire adult life you know
Rani's there's just something kind of
magical about her she is just a little
magical Fujikawa
Kate's got a goal she wants to lose 25
pounds by spring helping her do that is
WW formerly known as weight watchers cuz
guess what she's not just the global
ambassador she's also a client people
say like well how do you it's just your
jeans and it's just hey it's like well
you can say that and that's you know
fine but it's a practice like everything
else
ww became this like sort of aha moment
for me and then Oprah called and I said
yes
oh wow say what Oprah calls what's that
call like with Oprah awesome is it
I mean it's Oprah I mean it's like a
dream you know you sort of talked really
seriously on the phone and then but
behind you're looking at everyone in the
room why
look let's be honest when Oprah calls
yes you answer in you're giddy but at
the same time Kate really is becoming a
mobile and that's what I love all the
ways that she is blowing up her business
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]